my name is Spencer Shannon back and I'm
here to
about restful api best practices using
asp.net web api now if you're not a web
developer if you don't use web api
that's totally ok a lot of what I have
what up what I talked about you can
apply to using restful api s and knowing
when they're good and bad or apply them
later I talked a lot about a lot of
theoretical stuff so before I get
started I wanted to make sure that you
all know that everything that I'm
telling you today the slides writ links
to all the things that I talk about all
available at rest is net you'll also see
my twitter handle at night and box at
the bottom right I tweeted out a link
and it'll be on every slide so if you
want to take a picture now that's cool
but you can see it see it down here
later and then you can go to my Twitter
and check it out for yourself
all right so I wanted to start off by
talking a little bit about why I give
this talk ok so I give this talk for a
couple of reasons
first I think the information is good I
think it's I think it's compelling and I
think it's interesting but more than
anything it's therapeutic this is
therapy for me this is therapy because
I'm an integrator it's what I do I make
software talk to other software and I've
used good api's but far in a way I've
used way more bad api's and we're going
to spend some time today making fun of
those bad api's I'm gonna give you
plenty of good examples and plenty of
bad examples right and it's important
this is an important topic to talk about
because at the end of the day developers
have the power of choice right if you
have an application and your manager
comes to you and says we'd like to
integrate text messaging into your into
our application you can either be a
hacker and you know network together 40
Android phones and put Linux on them and
then you know create your own text text
messaging network could do that but
you're probably going to go out and find
an API to use write an API to consume
and there's lots of them for text
messaging you're going to go out and
you're going to compare and you're going
to compare all of these and you're going
to look for a few different things right
off the bat right you're going to look
for how quickly is it to go from 0 to
make magic happen and you're going to
hear me say that a lot make magic happen
because when you make an HTTP call and
then you look at your phone and you see
a text message it's kind of a cool
feeling it kind of feels like magic
right that's awesome you're going to
find out how quickly it is you go from 0
to make magic happen how quickly can I
get things done
next thing you're going to look for is
how quickly is it for me to how easy is
it for me to go and learn stuff more
about your API and manage problems or
manage exceptions right because
inevitably you'll probably make a bad
call here there we all do I certainly do
and so you're going to want to know how
can I solve those problems right we're
essentially looking for good
documentation and then you're going to
look at the long term benefit because
you're a discerning developer you want
your company to do well right so you're
going to probably look for things like
uptime or talk about things like cost
you're probably going to look at the
cost to compare the two and this is
really important because at the end of
the day you're going to go to your
manager and you're going to say hey I
found these text messaging platforms I
found these three text messaging
platforms that we could use and this one
that I found immediately I could get be
productive right away so you're not I'm
not spending a lot of time on this
they're great documentation they have a
great support line and the costs are
similar and your managers probably gonna
look at you and say ok and you've become
a customer for them and that was in your
power because at the end of the day you
have the power of choice right you can
choose to consume that API now you may
do five cents worth of text messaging
you could do 55 thousand dollars worth
of text messaging or pound from where I
am right I know that I integrated text
messaging at at a client of mine a while
ago and they spend thousands a month and
a large part of the decision was mine to
figure out what API is going to provide
the best short and long-term benefits
right now think about that that's on one
side that's as a consumer but think
about the other side if you have an
application that you work on that you
need to provide an API for what is it
going to be what is it going to take to
create something that is better than the
competition right you're going to be on
the flip side of that you're going to
say what can I do to make my API awesome
make it well-documented make sure that
it works make sure that it's obvious and
accessible right to developers so
there's two sides of that coin because
at the end of the day API design is user
experience for developers
now I thought of that yesterday and I
hurriedly typed it into google like oh
this is a cool thought and then like I
found out a hundred other people had
said this already so I'm pretty sure I
read that like six months ago and
thought oh this is
original idea but it really was a really
made sense to me because if you're
making an application a web application
WinForms whatever you're going to keep
your user in mind because you want them
to have a good experience you're going
to make sure that the form is laid out
properly and at the button there in the
right place and that they have good
visual cues to make sure that they're
progressing to the application naturally
and you want to do the same thing and
you want to have the same thing done for
you when looking at or crafting an API
it's the same principle
user experience for developers because
it's not hard I mean we're not we're not
shy folks right we're not shy people if
something's wrong with it we're going to
say something right I think this quote
does a good job of summing it up you
don't make usability a priority you'll
never have to worry about scalability
which essentially means like if nobody
wants to use your API because it sucks
that bad then you're not going to have
to worry about how quickly you can scale
up 40 Azure servers to handle the
additional traffic cause it's probably
not going to exist right there here are
some common schemes in this talk there's
a few common things you're going to see
over and over again you're going to see
these you're going to see a green
checkmark and a red X you're going to
see this a lot the green checkmarks is a
good guideline then the red X is
something that maybe you shouldn't do or
maybe you should avoid now these aren't
hard and fast rules nothing that I'm
telling you is but for 90% of them
you're going to put you're going to
apply 90% of what I tell you probably to
your API and it's going to work for you
there may be one or two exceptions here
and there and that's okay you can manage
by exception a little bit sure you're
also going to hear me talk about simple
is not easy making something that's
really simple for your consumers to use
is not an easy task crafting good so yes
you could make you could make an API you
can do a file new project in Visual
Studio and make an API pretty quickly
and then install a package that displays
help Docs for that API right and that's
good you can do that in like 10 minutes
right it's quick but it's not enough
because you're going to need to talk
about authentication you're going to
need to talk about exception handling
you're going to need to document what
weird little things about your API exist
right crafting good documentation takes
time and it takes thoughtfulness and
it's not easy right making an API that's
consistent consistent from endpoint to
endpoint you make sure that you use put
requests every time you want an update
an object right having those
conversations with your team and with
your manager that takes time and it
takes thoughtfulness and it's not easy
but it's so critical if you want people
to use your application and use your API
you have to make it simple for them but
simple is not easy you're going to hear
me say that a lot I'm also here to tell
you there's no silver bullet anybody who
stands in front of one of these stages
and says this is the this is the way and
the light you know you ought to think
twice about listening to them because
I've never found that to be true
there's good ideas there's bad ideas
there's some times when bad ideas are
good ideas right so most of what I'm
telling you is applicable it's awesome
it's good information but you're going
to have your own exception and like I
said there's no silver bullet there's no
magic answer I can't tell you that there
is one way one light right so we need to
talk about we're going to talk about
restful api is we ought to talk about
what rest is Right rest stands for
representational state transfer and it
was described in a paper by a guy named
Roy fielding he did it for his PhD
dissertation and it essentially
describes the architecture that is the
web okay it just it essentially it's not
tied to a protocol and it's not tied to
a particular format right it's just a
set of constraints a set of things that
if you have these things in common with
a system it can be considered a restful
system and here's what they are we have
six constraints we have the
client-server constraint which means
mainly just specifies that there's a
client and there's a server that's it we
have the cashable constraint which means
that a response from a server can define
itself as cashable or not it doesn't
have to be but it can define itself as
cashable there's the statelessness one
how many folks are asp.net users ok
ceremony how many of you are ASP now
that web forms users okay come on now if
there's that many hands you got to raise
them up I know there's more of you and
there you're shy I still use it too it's
okay all right
web forms is all right it's at its time
I still use it right and when you use
web forms you store things you store
data between page requests and sessions
right and then is stored on the server
you session state all the things that is
decidedly not stateless stateless means
that all the state that's contained for
is for a given web request is contained
within the request itself right so the
request sends all the information in a
purely restful system the the server
does not store anything right all the
data that it needs is made in the
request a system can be layered which
Smith simply means that a client can
make a request and it could come from
the response to that request could come
from the web server a load balancer a
cache server a CDN and it doesn't really
care and it the client doesn't care as
long as it gets its information code on
demand is the only optional constraint
and it simply means that at demand a
server can send additional code from
itself to the client in order to enhance
the experience or change the experience
the easiest example of that being
JavaScript right then there's the
uniform interface constraint which
itself is made up of four constraints
which are important to talk about so
we're going to talk about resource
identification is the first thing that
means that a given resource can be
identified by a URI right a URI or a URL
right and so when you make that request
the server goes and it gives you back
some data in this case I'm making a
request for employee 1 2 3 4 and I'm
getting back jacent object with the
first name in the last name right and
it's important to note that these are
representations of the data
these aren't these aren't the data
itself right it's not if this comes from
a sequel server database you know it's
not the API is not telling you oh this
is a sequel server and here's the table
that it lives in and here's the row
number and here's every attribute on
that right it doesn't have any of that
information it doesn't give you back
that it gives you back a representation
but that's okay because representations
have meaning and those representations
can be used to manipulate the resources
on the server right so if you did pick
that and you change the name and you
send a put request to the server you can
change in theory change via change the
employee object content is self
descriptive which means that the server
tells the client what kind of content is
being sent back it could be Jason it
could be XML it could be a CSS file it
could be HTML right the point is is that
it described
so it typically describes itself in HTTP
inside of the the the content type
header inside of the response right then
the final one is Haiti OS or hyper media
as the engine of application state which
is important to talk about because in
the restful system a client doesn't know
everything about what's going on in the
server right if you go to google.com the
client is getting information from
Google to say I'm going to navigate to
the I'm going to navigate to maps or I
want to navigate to the shopping at the
shopping area of Google or I want to do
a Google search the client doesn't know
all that stuff intrinsically the server
provides all the information that it
needs that the client needs to navigate
that's Katie OS and we're going to talk
about how that applies to restful api s
okay
speaking of rest what's the restful api
right a restful api is just an api that
follows the rest architecture which I
know is probably mind-blowing but really
is that simple but the term is a little
bit been co-opted it's been kind of kind
of brought on a 10-2 taking a life of
its own right because rest isn't tight
remember rest is a set of constraints
it's not a protocol it's not a it's not
a tied to a particular format right it's
not tied to Jason it's not even tied to
HTTP now granted most restful systems
are HTTP systems but they're not tied
together and when people say restful api
usually what they mean is adjacent an
HTTP api that returns Jason or sometimes
XML and that's what people think for the
purposes of this talk we're going to
talk as if we're going to go with the
the common definition or the peep the
well understood definition when I say
restful api I'm just going to refer to
an HTTP API that probably returned some
kind of JSON or XML we're going to use
JSON and all of our examples so we're
gonna stick with that just a just for
the sake of clarity right so I'm here to
tell you though you there's pragmatism
involved right a purely restful api does
not make it a good api write an api that
strictly follows the rest standard now
the rest constraint model does not make
it a good HTTP api okay or a good
restful api and i'll give you an example
hey Theo Oz is a perfect example
hypermedia is the engine of application
State so a lot there's a lot of debate
out there whether adjacent API or any
API in general should send back links to
related content inside of the JSON
response so for example if you make a
request for a customer a customer if
you're an accounting system has invoices
associated with it right so you might
send back a link to say here's where you
would get those invoices right you'd get
you it would send back that link in the
in the header or sorry in the response
but that has really limited usefulness
because from an API consumption
standpoint you probably need the invoice
API you probably already know how to
access it
but that's a purely restful thing so if
they say you know what we've got to do
pure rest we mean it can't be a RESTful
API without haiti hola so now we have to
spend all this time and by the way
that's not an easy thing to do to
implement on an AP HTTP or a restful api
right it's not it takes a lot of extra
work and what we have to wait we have to
because it's restful but if you get
everything else wrong if you're if it's
poorly documented there's a lot of
downtime right then your api your api is
probably not good right so I'm here to
tell you to do what makes sense and
throw everything else out okay now let
me ask you is that vague enough for you
right like that seems pretty vague
that's not very helpful and it's mainly
because again there's no silver bullet
there's no ant there's no one way one
path what I say works for me
for most gates for the most part when I
design API it may not work for you right
so we're going to treat the API we're
going to talk about how to build an API
now the restful api let's get to
building it or designing it right we're
going to talk about the design process
now I'm going to talk about it as if
it's siloed to design implement document
maintain in reality you're probably
doing all of these things at once right
you're probably iterating and there's
probably one big circle right but for
the sake of this talk we'll just talk
about these in the siloed way right all
right I've been practicing so when it
comes to API design I have one rule okay
I actually have two rules but that
sounds a lot cooler and then I can put
the Dark Knight up on the slide right
and it's keep it simple stupid or if
you're nice
keep it simply keep it stupidly simple
right and
and simple isn't easy what we're going
to talk about some ways that you're
going to make you can make it simple and
again our Navy but you want people to
use your API right so first rule keep it
simple don't be creative let me give you
an example of creative so when you're
making an HTTP request to a resource
it's very common to get back some kind
of Eric or some kind of response code
other than just 200 to say everything's
good right you might send a bad request
to an API and they say actually you're
missing the first name we're going to
send 400 bad request one example of
creative is I know of an API where every
single call that you make returns 200
okay and the body of the robada of the
response actually contains whether or
not there was a problem with that
response right it'll actually contain
whether or not there was an error that
API is also managed by a company called
Facebook so they can have they could be
creative right they can be a little
creative but for the most part you
shouldn't be should follow the general
rules and general guidelines that I laid
out do what developers expect it's the
bottom line provide what is necessary
and no more and no less now this is
another example of it's really hard
simple is not easy right so but there's
some general rules so if you're an
accounting application and you have an
employee end point and you want to
return to list of employees it's likely
you don't want to return their social
security number appearance from the
United States I don't know they have an
equivalent here I'm sure they do some
kind of identifying number that's
important that is pretty sensitive
information that you don't want to send
back on the other hand you want to make
sure that you send back enough
information about that employee to be
useful right you don't want to leave out
their first name right that wouldn't
make a lot of sense but knowing what
this looks like can be really hard again
simple is not easy so you have to
provide enough information for your
consumer for the information be useful
right and then use a handful of HTTP
status codes the best API is that I
consume used less than 10 right there's
about a hundred plus HTTP status codes
there's even one called I'm a little
teapot and I'm not making that like for
18 or something you could use that one
but nobody does and you shouldn't be
there and you should just use a subset
use a good subset right and he
a few that you could use that are good
examples 200 okay you send it back with
a get request to say everything's cool
here's your response right everything's
good 201 created when you do a post
request and you create an object right
you could send back 201 created to say
yep everything's good your resources
created 400 bad request another common
one and I would argue the most important
when doing integration work or doing API
work because if there's an exception if
there's a problem getting this request
and everything around it right the bad
400 bad request getting that response
correct is very critical it's just
basically a way of saying your request
wasn't any good just change if and
ideally it would tell you how to change
it and then send it back right and then
it'll be good and you can get 200 ok and
move on with your life 404 not found of
course if a Reese if you're asking for
an employee that doesn't exist 2 3 4 5
sent back for form and then 401 and 403
unauthorized and forbidden which folks
tend to get mixed up right 401
unauthorized says I don't know who you
are
403 forbidden says I know who you are
and you can't do that right you can't
look at that social security number
here's an example so this is my favorite
part these are the part where I get to
tell stories stories that are real these
are things every example that I'm
showing you of a bad API is an example
that comes from a real experience ok so
let's talk about keeping it simple in
the context of this so there's an API
that I interact with where every one of
their objects has a separate has a name
ID and that name ID points to a separate
ID on a name resource little literally
only returns an ID in a string with the
name right so in order for me to get the
complete picture of this customer I
either have to do two requests right or
n plus 1 request if I'm getting a list
of customers then I have to do if I get
a list of customers and then I have to
do to get the names of that that's
horrible
why would you make me do that that's not
keeping it simple that's awful that's
two requests per get and if I'm making
the request because the opposite is true
if I'm trying to create that customer I
have to create a name object first and
then I have to create the customer that
what what's the point why would you make
me do that
why would you make me do two requests
for every
seeing one of your objects awful but the
bottom line is don't let your specific
implementations leak into your
abstraction because it's ibadah at the
end of the day an API is an abstraction
right it's an abstraction over your
system and a lot of people say that
abstractions leak things like enemy
framework right that are good Oh RM
tools but they're leaky because they try
to cover up all the you know parts of
sequel server that nobody wants to know
so usually it's they say abstractions
are leaky but the others true - they've
let their implementation leak into their
API because I happen to know I asked
them I they said oh yeah we store names
in the separate table I said okay I
can't really criticize that they
probably have a very good reason
actually for this particular company
they probably don't they probably have a
very good reason or if they thought they
had a good reason for doing that so I'm
not criticizing their implementation I'm
criticizing the fact that they've not
kept it simple for me as their consumer
I'd much rather see this right just one
request one post request or get requests
to get the name and then oh you know the
developer on the other end says but but
but then I have to like manage the name
object myself yeah yeah make it simple
you want to make it simple on me you
don't want to make it hard I'd much
rather see something like this right
wouldn't you you want to make two
requests for every object I don't how
about this I've put three words up on
the screen theory Anakin threshold
I've given I've told you nothing about
them you know they're English word right
and not American words they're English
words but I didn't tell you anything
about them I just put them on the screen
and I just expect you to know or don't
what they are what if I told you that
and this is true this is the name of my
former neighbors kids okay how would you
know that unless I told you first of all
it's really weird okay they also have
lilia but lily is like a normal name
right it's like the most normal of the
names right the examples not nearly as
funny with her first but I didn't tell
you this I didn't give you any context I
didn't give you any context up front
you're left wondering what the words
mean how does that tie into this I'll
give you this okay so I put four more
words on the screen and as a developer
you look at that as engineer you say
okay those kind of mean the same thing
like inactive and
deleted or inactive and retired that
kind of similar so maybe they describe
different states of an object right it's
either inactive or deleted or visible or
retired right what if I told you that on
several one of these several objects
these are four separate properties these
are four separate properties on each of
those objects right here's the best part
not only is it not well documented what
each of these individually mean the
developers don't even know what they
mean in combination with each other so
if oh if something is inactive and
visible well it follows this set of
rules what is that like that's more
that's like 16 or 24 permutations right
and they don't they can't tell me what
each of these mean if the object is in
this different state that's not keeping
it simple and they haven't even they
haven't even proved to me that the
complexity of this is worth my time to
manage they haven't even documented it
they didn't they don't even know
honestly so that's not keeping it simple
right it makes me go like oh this is
just a gross awful awful API design or
if you knew this company you would not
be surprised
second big rule be consistent and
honestly this is really saying the same
thing as keep it simple right be
consistent with accepted best practices
and be consistent with yourself right
now accepted best practices is a bit of
a well best practice is a subjective
thing right but it's up to you and your
team if you're designing a restful api
to do some research do some talking
right just kind of figure out what's
best practices apply typically speaking
you want to return 200 okay with with a
good request and not 200 okay with a bad
request right like those are pretty
common things it gets a little murky but
you can you can form your own opinion
and then if you do it one way stick with
it and if you have to deviate even a
little bit document document document
right but try to be consistent with
yourself if you say I'm going to create
all objects with put requests which is
would be creative and bad then do it at
least at least be consistent across your
endpoints there's one in particular API
that I can think of where instead of
using put requests to update objects
they use patch requests and that's
unusual and speaking of which let's talk
about some HTTP verbs because they're at
least the most
one's right because there's like more
than this but I don't know what they are
because I don't need to know because I'm
trying to stay consistent right so get
requests just get data that's all they
do
put requests are typically used to
update data so you're trying to update
an employee you give it up you do a put
request and then you update that
employee right typically with put
requests you send everything you say
send all the properties if it's missing
a property it assumes that you don't
want that property anymore
and in theory and what people expect is
that the property would be set to null
or whatever that equivalent would be on
the back-end system right post requests
typically used for creating objects okay
I also see post requests you sometimes
in place of put that's less common but I
have seen it to me I use put requests
separately because it's just what
developers expect right
delete usually use for deleting
individual resources I saw an API once
though where they had a delete request
that you could issue against a whole
resource so API slash employees and it
would just delete all the employees okay
I wouldn't do that yes if you could if
you wanted to but it seems like a bad
idea and then patch request which patch
request just says I just it's like a put
request but you don't have to send
everything back it's less common to see
out in the wild but I do see it and it
just basically said I just want to
update these one or two properties right
remember to be consistent pick away and
stick with it if you're going to insist
that you do all your get requests with
posts and if you're going to be that
mean at least like D consistently mean
right and don't mutate data with gifts
get I've seen enough I've seen enough to
call it out ok I've actually where when
you do a get request developers expect
that it's not going to change anything
but you're only getting data from the
server but I've seen people do this I've
seen people mutate data which gets and
you shouldn't do that resource
identification so we have a concept of
mound versus verbs right so we have
nouns employee would be an example of an
out right get all employees would be an
example of a verb based system I'm not
talking HTTP verbs I'm just talking
word verbs right and here's what they
might look like you could get employee
get employees get a single employee or
post to the employees end point or you
can create verbs right you could say get
all employees get employees with ID get
employee with ID and so on
generally in restful so the one on the
right example on the right is more used
in like soap esque systems and that's
not a bad thing like I've used good soap
api's and bad rest api to leave me but
when it comes to creating a modern today
api that people expect to use use plural
nouns okay stick with the plural nouns
because it's consistent it's what people
expect now I promise if you use singular
nouns and you get everything else right
I promise you I will not stand up on the
stage and make fun of you I really won't
but most people expect it to be plural
so if you're starting something
Greenfield stick with plural nouns to
pick one or the other remember be
consistent yeah so you get a customer
you want to get the employee or you want
to get the invoices under that customer
right so there's a few different ways
that you might consider doing that you
can give them you can just return the
set of invoices within the parent object
that's an option typically that doesn't
work very well unless you're returning a
short list of things that doesn't change
often when you're talking about
employees especially in the context of
an accounting system sorry invoices in
the context of an accounting system
usually a customer will just keep
recurring invoices and invoices and
invoices so you probably don't want to
return it with the parent object because
that list could grow to a thousand or
more and then you're sending back data
that they may not even be using right
especially if you're getting a list of
customers and you really don't want to
do that much more common and much more
what you should consider is just getting
a sub resource using say customers no
idea the customer and then say I want to
get the invoices under this particular
customer it's a lot more common it's a
lot more common occasionally I run
across an API that uses expand typically
this is used for higher volume ap is
where they're trying to control what
data they send back they want to be
flexible and not have like a hundred
endpoints but at the same time they want
to give the developer an option to get
the invoices back with the parent object
I would typically shy away from this for
greenfield stuff I'd stick with the
middle one just said make it a separate
request right the expand for ammeter I
find too many consumers just say oh I'll
just take all the things you know I'll
just expand every possible option and
then what's the API consumer to do it's
nice for higher volume API is likely
probably not necessary but whatever you
do be consistent right and I'm just
going to say that till I'm blue in the
face that it's simple isn't easy and
keep it simple right but consistency is
key but be flexible where it makes sense
and again it's pretty vague right but
like I can't come up here and tell you
that the answer to this particular
scenario is the right answer for you
when we're doing get requests there are
some things that we should consider
about the implementation of our get
request we may want to sort the data
filter the data or page the data this is
where I'm getting into a little bit of
Microsoft D Web API ish stuff so you
know bear with me if that's not your bag
but in this case we're doing we're doing
a request to the contoso API we want to
get some people and we want to order by
name so what would what we would end up
with is a list of people ordered by name
right and this is using something called
OData this isn't built into web api but
you can use new get and install OData
and hook it up to your controllers it's
very convenient very easy I like it you
could also do things like this or order
by name descending and you can also
order by multiple fields so it's pretty
handy again it's OData you don't have to
remember that because you're going to
wreston is that net or twitter right to
look at this all up because you don't
want to remember this don't write down
anything that you don't have to remember
right filtering filtering is actually
pretty important so this is using the Oh
data filter and API you don't have to
use this but we're and we're going to
talk about where you wouldn't maybe but
in this case if you're if they know the
names of the fields on the other end you
might do something like this where you
say I want to filter I want to say name
operator and then whatever you're
comparing it to right in this case we're
saying name equals milk and this is
extensible as well you can do something
like this that's really useful it's
really handy and we'll talk about how
that applies in a second but again you
get this for free
just Google this right take a picture
grab the slide deck whatever Google this
you get it for free and web api is
awesome paging is another important
consideration you should make right if
you want to get customers it's likely
something that you will have to worry
about you will have to think about
paging at some point especially if
you're returning a million records you
probably don't want to return them all
on one go
right so you're getting customers you
might want to page the data you say I
want page 1 I want this many in the page
and here's what the result might look
like it might have a page number it
might have a list of the results and it
might have a link to the next page
because you're a nice developer and
you're like I just want to make them
give them a while while next page does
not equal no and you know keep going to
let them get as many as they want I also
see limit offset used commonly in lots
of API
either's fine just you know pick one and
stick with it be consistent right and
typically if you're implementing paging
it's because you want to put a limit on
the number of records I've used api's
where they gave me a page and a page
size parameter I had to use it but they
didn't put a maximum on the page size so
then I could just get all the records
anyway so if you're using paging it's
likely because you want to do some kind
of filtering and keep them keep your API
from returning too much data right
there's a good paging example on my blog
again link linked below but I have a
paging example that I wrote up Oh data
has paging in it it's not my favorite
implementation I'm not exactly a fan of
how it returns the data so I usually
just roll my own okay do you need this
do you need to sort a short page filter
maybe I don't know what are your
consumers need that should be the first
question in your API journey right is
what do your consumers need I will tell
you a couple of my opinion so paging
probably is something that you should
consider sorting and filtering so the
thing about filtering is is if you're
giving them the power to filter on
anything if that query is being trained
if you're using it with entity framework
even better because that translates to a
sequel query but if that's not indexed
and you're trying to filter on that that
can get a little hairy right it's very
common to include extra query parameters
to program it to make it so that you
include extra
query parameters to say things like I
only want the tools in this particular
category or I only want objects that
were modified after a certain date right
so that's pretty common
sorting weird weird and not common for
integration scenarios right because most
of the time I don't care what order the
data comes back I just want the data but
it might be useful if you're making like
a front-end application write an angular
or aralia or something and you're making
an API for the backend you might want to
implement sorting for yourself
right that might be an internally
consumed API where sort of makes sense
versioning is really critical it's
really critical to at least think about
because your API should stand a test of
time but note I didn't say the test of
time I just said a test of time because
you have to keep and keep in mind the
lifecycle of your REST API it's not
going to last forever now my mom she's a
COBOL programmer and she works on
systems that use as/400 and have since
the 60s okay a little bit different your
API is probably not going to last that
long right but you have to keep that in
mind you have to keep in mind is this
going to be useful for an extended
period of time do I plan on making a new
one to address consumer needs in a
couple years you have to at least think
about that right and there's definitely
there's different ways to version your
API these are the ones that I see that
are most common so a lot of now I
wouldn't say a lot a fair number of API
implementers do something where they do
a get request and you're getting or
posting to customers you post to the
same URL but you provide a version
number in the header of the request okay
it's a little bit I would I see it but
it's to me it's not obvious it's not
obvious that especially if the objects
have a different structure if I'm
expecting something different back on a
get request it's not entirely obvious I
don't like this strategy but I do see it
I'd much prefer something like this
where you're putting the version number
in the URL right so that way you're
saying I'm running version 1 of this
customer's API and then I can say if I
need version 2 great I can just call a
different end point it's much more
obvious here's something here's an
example of somebody getting creative
so stripe is a payment processing API
it's pretty popular and they use a mixed
stress
they have their major versions segmented
out by a URL but then if you have a
minor version like a tweak that you need
like some some additional thing they'll
have minor versions of their API and you
can distinguish between those inside of
the header which i think is kind of
handy you likely won't need to do that
but the creative example so I threw it
in there it's kind of cool use URL
versioning it'll save you trouble it'll
save your consumer struggle it's obvious
well it's much more obvious errors are
going to happen problems with your API
are going to happen the question is how
are you going to manage those problems
right so let me show you an example
that's a bad example and it's using a
real API that change you know to protect
the innocent or not but I need to create
a vendor so I do a post request to
create a vendor but it requires name and
the state right and I give it the the
name of the vendor but I don't give it
the state right I don't say Missouri or
whatever then I get back a bad request
that sister returns application jason
says this is jason and then it returns a
string that says state is required okay
that's a Matson that's an error message
that's something I can do something with
useful limited usefulness we'll talk
about that in a second right so let's do
in a post to a different end point so
we're going to create an employee and
requires a first and last name all right
and I just give it a first name because
I'm just trying it out and see if I can
break it then it returns back 400 bad
request it's also returns back Jason but
it returns back to Jason object that
wraps inside of an error message it just
says your request was invalid okay now
both of these examples are pretty bad
examples and this is a real API again
this is not something I haven't seen
right where they return one format in
one end and one on another and this is
like this is weird to me so they're bad
so the first one is bad because what if
there's multiple properties that are
invalid I want to know about each of
those so I can fix them fix the problem
that much quicker then on the other end
it wraps it in an object which is sort
of like a beginning because if it's
wrapped in an object maybe they'll
eventually return or at least an array
or something of errors right but it
doesn't even tell me what's wrong right
a good
combination that I see a good approach
is usually to return like an array of
errors that say here's an error with
this particular property and here's the
error message you know it's either
formatted incorrectly or entirely
missing
I like this err this kind of error
reporting so again I'll say it again
simple isn't easy
this is pulled from Twilio documentation
a little hard to see but what they
return to you is not only do they return
an error message they return a specific
error code that's tied explicitly to
that error message then they give you a
link to the documentation on how to fix
it and phone numbers are weird because
phone numbers come in lots of different
formats and actually Twilio makes it
really easy because you can give them a
phone number that has parentheses or
hyphens right and it doesn't really care
but if the bad word but but if you send
in like I don't know a plus sign and
you've got the wrong country code that
could be a problem and so they give you
a link back to some documentation that
you can use to fix your problem that's
awesome that's great you got to make
confining and fixing errors on your
consumer as easy as possible okay that's
the bottom line you've got to keep it
simple for them it's simple isn't easy
but you got to keep it simple for them
so that you'll use it talk about
security so I've got two facets that I
want to go over you know fairly quickly
is that in encryption and authentication
so a bottom line is you should be using
SSL all right there's no reason not to
anymore you can get free certificates
via let's encrypt org right and then you
can automate it so that it perpetually
requests new certificates and it works
in perpetuity I did that to my blog if
you go to Schneids net you'll see that
it's encrypted
why did I have to feel the need to
encrypt blog traffic and I don't really
know but I did it because it was there
and it took me about four hours to do so
if I it takes me four hours it can take
you like to write use SSL and don't roll
your own encryption please don't roll
your own encryption and this is just
like a general rule all right let me
tell you a story this is real so there
was an encryption library that had a
vendor name and then it just said
encryption DLL right it was the name of
the software company and then they said
ok you need a key here in this text file
and then in your application settings
you need another key ok so very very
cryptic
very like mysterious like you need
multiple keys like this is really cool
and we were using it to in encrypt
social security numbers sensitive data
and so I was looking at the social
security numbers one day not the real
lunch that the encrypted ones and I
started noticing kind of a pattern it's
like okay they're all roughly the same
length no they all are the same length
and see the characters repeated over and
over again what they had for us was a
library that essentially was a
substitution cipher they literally were
substituting nine for like the Y with
two dots above it and I and I noticed
this and I told my manager and he kind
of laughed because he used to work there
thankfully didn't touch that but don't
roll your own there's plenty of
encryption out there that you can use
it's plenty of encryption libraries you
will do it wrong they will do it right I
would do it wrong I just wouldn't try
and then pick an authentication strategy
that isn't basic basic authentication
meaning with your API you send a
username and password which is common
and pretty easy to get started the
problem is is that basic authentication
is like giving you keys to your house to
your house sitter and saying I'm going
to be gone for a week so watch my house
and you're letting the the sitters like
okay and then you hand them the number
of your checking account when you hand
them the combination to your safe right
you're just giving them all access
privileges to your house you're giving
them free reign and that's not very
manageable Twitter use basic
authentication for a long time they
eventually got rid of it because they
didn't want people to be passing their
username and passwords to a vendor who
might store them improperly and then use
them to make requests and then you're
just giving them the keys of the kingdom
now you can tweet out all sorts of weird
stuff right they didn't Twitter said no
you want to be able to oh oh office a
very good strategy for consumer-facing
API applications where you need to where
a consumer needs to interact and give
permission right a loss is what Twitter
uses what Facebook uses you basically
give direct them to a login and then it
says here's what this application wants
to do here's what it can't do and then
it sends back a token for that
application to use to do those things
right that's much more scalable because
those tickets or those tokens can be
refreshed they can be revoked by the
user at any time much more scalable and
much better for security alright so
let's look at some code example I'm
gonna look at the screen here because oh
good okay so that says that doesn't look
too bad I was worried that it would be
too small but let's go over what a
controller looks like so that's we're
actually looking at some Web API code so
we have here our employees controller
it's just a class declaration that
inherits from API controller if you're
using asp.net core you would just
inherit from controller and then we have
our route at the top we say we want this
to be API version 1 of employees alright
so cool we're on the way we're
implementing a good versioning strategy
I like that
and we got our get requests which get
data we have the top one which just
returns a list of employees and then we
have the one below it which returns ones
particular employee and it has a little
route attribute to say we expect an ID
of type end to be here and then we get
that as an argument to our method and
then that gets executed awesome then we
have our employee post which takes an
employee in now if you've ever made an
API in visual studio you can create a
new project and then right click on the
controllers and then add you know create
your model and then right click on the
controllers folder and hit add
controller and then you can do something
called scaffolding where it just
generates all the code for you and if
you're using entity framework it's like
double the awesome right because then it
just makes a controller for you that
implements or gets your puts through
your posts and your delete and it does
it all against an entity framework
database which is awesome right actually
not awesome
so one of the things that's really bad
and there's a lot of maintainability
problems around that a lot of security
problems - such as how are we
controlling what the employee object has
on it so now is does this mean that any
property that they post back to this
employee endpoint can be updated what if
there's a social security number right
or the opposite could be true they get
requests to include those by default
right so that's bad that's insecure the
better option is to use what's called a
dto or data transfer object or even a
per request object when I create api's
all of my controllers each of the
requests has a different class
associated with it for that request so
if I'm creating an employee I'm
I'm creating a class called employee
post request it takes extra code but
it's very explicit and it's very
maintainable we'll talk about why in a
little bit what about this
okay so we've we've implemented that and
we just we've said let's D TOS all the
way right DT of all the things so let's
separate our concerns right this is a
little little harder to read so I'll
break it down for you a little bit so
we're taking an order this is an order
controller so we're taking an order DT
oh so that a customer can make an order
right so we're going to create a new
order we're going to add all the items
in the order DT Oh to that order and
then we're going to save it to the
database okay and then your controller
you know your controllers done some
magic and that's and that's awesome
right the problem is is that the
controller knows too much the controller
knows how to - too much and you see the
bottom line is a controller should be a
traffic cop they should be able to point
out where things go direct traffic like
this right but they should never know
how to do something they should know
where to go to do something but not how
ok and we'll show I'll give an example
of that in just a second we skip this
part the part about bad requests right
we're up there it says if model state is
valid it's check in that order DT Oh to
make sure that it's a valid object then
send back bad requests and that's good
because we want to send back bad
requests so they'll fix it and redo
their order maybe there was no cart
items in the cart for this order or
something right so then we implement
validation on our DT oh right we can add
those little attributes that say this
parameters required here's the range
right you can do that you can also
inherit from I validate able object
which just provides a method or not
inherit implement I validate able
objects which provides a method called
validate and then you can say you can do
some custom validation logic that's
that's maybe more custom than just using
those data annotations like required the
problem with this is that now the DTO
knows too much about how to validate
itself right what if you need to access
a database right you don't there's
there's no hooks for us to create a new
order dto passing in our database
container right you could do it up
inside of there but that's not really a
good idea so what are you supposed to do
we'll talk about that in a second the
bottom line is is that better that this
is better than nothing right this is
better than nothing
you should validate validate validate
validate all the things assume that all
data that you're getting is bad until
you validated it and you should separate
your validation logic from your object
your dto should not know how to validate
itself
I like this library it's called fluent
validation and what you end up doing is
for than order DTO you would create an
order detail validator class and then
you can test that independently here's
what the architecture of one of an API
that I would make uses so we have a
controller the controller gets a request
the request gets routed to a validator
right and then that validator once it's
passed that it passes it on to a handler
or service that then processes that
request you notice everything is broken
down yes it's more lines of code but as
your API grows in complexity and you
need to maintain it it will save you
tons of hours it'll save you tons of
time and then of course it's just good
for separation of concerns and
testability because we're all unit
testing all these things right right
Google mediator if you know if you use a
library called Auto mapper which I use
Auto mapper all the time especially in
web api mediator was written by the guy
Jimmy Bogart it's an awesome library
it's a very simple low API surface it's
a good it's a good one to implement the
pattern where you go request handler
that kind of thing mediators awesome
documentation is so critical and there's
a lot you have to think about you have
to think about the endpoints that you're
documenting you have to think about the
parameters those endpoints take you have
to think about the schema of the data
that you're sending and receiving you
have to talk about how it's formatted
because if you're because if you're
using JSON and you're expecting a date
right you wanted an ISO 8601 format or
maybe you wanted in you know short date
time format you have to specify that you
have to talk to that you have to you
know engage with your users and tell
them this is what you're expecting and
then you have to tell them about how to
fix errors or how to manage exceptions
right and there's so much that goes into
this making the doubt Navigant page
easy-to-navigate right making it easy to
read making it so that you document
everything that allows them to go soup
to nuts down your API right so you could
document authentication for example
really important part to document the
bottom line is is a good API lives and
dies by its documentation by far I'd
rather consume a bad API with good dot
with awesome documentation than a good
API with no documentation at all every
time because if it's well documented at
least it's at least I can expect I can
kind of work my work my way through the
muck work my way through the weirdness
right but it's a good API and I
encounter a problem and the message that
I get back is vague and there's no
documentation that sucks but if it's not
a good API anyways has got good
documentation it should be if it's a
good API it's got good documentation or
you should tweet that out because that's
awesome it's like I thought of that it
was like great maintaining your API this
is kind of a big one this is a
conversation that I had recently with
one of the API vendors which we have a
lot of customers under write they said
hey we're making under some under the
cover the changes they're not changing
any of the they're not changing into the
objects they're not changing you need to
get there just making some under the
cover changes but they shouldn't impact
you but let me know if it breaks
something let us know if it breaks
something okay that should send up a red
flag it's end up like a hundred for this
company it's no this is no different
right just this is just a normal day
well we said hey okay you know can we
run our integration test can you release
it to test so that way we can run our
test suite against it and make sure
everything's cool no we need it in an
hour so we're going to deploy it in an
hour right so not only did they warn us
that there could be breaking changes is
that they couldn't even anticipate but
they said we're going to release it to
production in an hour anyway and you
know screw your customers if you have
customers right and this is like so
totally wrong on so many levels right
this is just terrible idea this is just
terrible API practice and I asked them
about unit testing they're like how are
we supposed to do that unit test what's
that right so I knew that they weren't
doing that and that just made this even
harder thankfully there weren't any
issues
at time maintaining your API a large
part of it should be fixing bugs and
optimizing so you don't want to optimize
too far ahead of time right you know
premature optimization is the root of
all evil I live by that but if you're if
there's opportunities for better
performance and they're significant then
take them right you know fix some bugs
if there's a bug with your API fix it
right do what they expect don't do
things like remove properties or add
properties or even add properties away
because I said we actually had that
happen to one of our vendors they added
properties for their API much after they
were released and we actually had a
property on there that on our class and
our c-sharp class that that shared that
property name and so what it tried to do
is it was was giving us a string and we
were trying to deserialize it into a
complex object and then of course Newton
soft-touch jason said you know naughty
I'm magic but I'm not that magic so then
that broke everything didn't break it
broke that one particular endpoint and
that was kind of sad we fixed it but
keep your API is consistent right if you
release it if you've provided that
contract don't add and certainly don't
remove okay so it's got eight minutes
left so this is the end of my talk if
you don't want more resources go to rest
nine sneck follow me on twitter look at
my Twitter account it's got a link to
this as well you can go to my website
I've got lots more information if I'll
take some questions since I'm asked to
have some extra time so if anybody has
any questions if you want to leave
please feel free but if you want to ask
questions by all means but other than
that my name is Spencer thank you very
much I appreciate your listening and
have the rest of us eat
[Applause]
so the question was what about a piece
away showed Asia API versioning in the
URL we showed it in the header what
about in the query string for like get
requests right I don't have any
particular experience my experience is
that it's better than my first initial
thought is that it's better than header
versioning but still not as good as like
putting it explicitly at the beginning
of the URL but at least it's a step in
the right direction so but I would
probably avoid it I mean if I were
making an API I might use it for minor
versioning but I have not even had an
opportunity to do minor versioning on an
API so probably wouldn't do that either
good question yes
say that again Oh
the question was about generating
documentation so there's some good tools
out there to generate your duck at least
start on your documentation because you
really don't want to sit and like go
property by property like some of that
can be done for you swagger is a good
option so what I use but it's often used
in substitute for like not documenting
at all and it's good but you should
still fill in the gaps with like here's
the exception here's how errors should
look when you return it when I'm
returning a problem here's how errors
look here's how you have sent a case you
still have to bridge those gaps but it's
at least a good start good question yes
how do you oh great question how do you
handle versioning in code me personally
so the way that I structure my
applications heavily relies on
dependency injection so what I do is I
actually have my controllers in a
completely separate library and then
when I start up my application I use
dependency injection to read though to
read that library and then inject those
different version controllers into my
asp net runtime so I so I you don't have
to use dependency injection you ought to
but to answer your question specifically
usually I just store them in a separate
project and just differentiate them by
using different routes do I have any
code examples I think the let's see if I
can find a good one here the one that I
think would be most applicable if you
could use your imagination just a little
bit is if you could have an employee and
employees v1 controller right that has
that route prefix at the top and then
you can have another employees v2
controllers that has a different route
prefix API v2 you could keep them in the
same library I put them in separate
libraries personally can I like to keep
things separate separate is good great
question great question
yes
so the question was about validation
like if I don't the object doesn't
validate itself how do I validate it so
I use fluent validation and fluent
validation gives me gives me a tool
where I can just I create a class and I
inherit from their validator class and
then I define my validation rules in the
constructor so it would say rule for
first name is that it can't be empty and
empty means not an empty string and not
null so that's how I handle that I keep
my validator separate from my D POS or
request objects yes so so the question
was where do you pass the validation so
I have it hooked up in my pipeline such
that my controller routes my request
through about through all the validators
that it can find and then it goes if all
the validators pass then it goes into my
handler and actually does my service
great question yes
great question so the question is how do
I handle deprecation right if I'm forced
to break something how do i how do I
handle that typically in an API we're in
the API world what you would do is you
give there first of all you'd give your
consumers a lot of notice when you
deprecated it that means that at some
point you're in the near future you want
to retire it if you're going to do that
it's best to create another version of
your end of your API and another version
of that endpoint and a lot and then
point them to that and say you use that
version at that point you probably think
it's at the point where you're probably
thinking about doing that you're
probably looking to the future anyways
to say I'm going to implement API 2.0
but the worst thing you can do is give
your consumers like very little notice
nothing would piss them off more
seriously like if you gave them we're
going to set this API down in a month
like even six months isn't really enough
like more like a year but if you're
doing that you're probably looking at
the next version of your API great
question yes right right
okay so the question was is the ordering
and filtering using the query string
because that in the query string yes and
then and then right okay so the question
is about having a single query
filterable query parameter versus
multiple using it so you can use the
filter parameter if you're using oh data
you can use that single one much more
commonly I don't see Oh data out in the
wild much I like it because it's
convenient and it works well for what I
use it for but it's much more common to
have multiple query parameters on an
endpoint that filter it in some way and
they're all usually optional so they
could say it might be modified after or
part of a certain category and then you
can filter it out based on based on the
query parameters that you provide and I
see that much more commonly all okay and
is it a single get it yeah we typically
a single get yep well now I say
typically but I've never seen that no
usually it's just one get with multiple
query parameters great question all
right well I'm out of time and I want to
let the next speaker up on the stage so
thank you so much for coming thank you
very much